how's it going everybody we have some
pretty great news for the Marvel
community today
Benedict Cumberbatch has signed a new
contract to play the one and only dr.
Stephen strange his new contract brought
him a considerable pay raise but most
importantly brings us more Doctor
Strange movies quick reminder that the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway continues
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero so although it
has been a while we finally have a
Doctor Strange 2 movie on its way they
will begin filming Doctor Strange 2 in
early 2019 and they'll also be taking
Doctor Strange 2 over to London
Disney has a studio in London in fact
they are filming spider-man far from
home there right now and although we
haven't seen it it was mentioned in the
first Doctor Strange movie that there is
a sanctum in London obviously right now
we do not know what would take Doctor
Strange over to the London sanctum but
I'm sure after Avengers 4 we will have a
better idea since the ending of Avengers
4 is going to wrap up the stories of the
first 10 years we can expect that as
these stories come to an end and get
wrapped up the newer story is going
forward in the MCU will be set up at the
end of Avengers 4 as well a question
does arise though since they will be
filming spider-man far from home in the
London studio and Doctor Strange in the
London studio presumably right after
will we perhaps see Doctor Strange in
spider-man far from home if you think
about it it makes sense that spider-man
would see Doctor Strange and spider-man
far from home we don't know what's going
to happen in Avengers 4 but in infinity
war spider-man and Doctor Strange were
introduced to each other
I'm Peter by the way Doctor Strange oh
you sure made up names um
I'm spider-man then and fought alongside
each other against Thanos so they will
most likely fight with each other again
in Avengers for that he will fight
Mysterio vulture two million hydro-man
and of recently molten man perhaps he
may get some help from the master of the
mystic arts as far as Doctor Strange 2
goes it has been said that nightmare
will be the main villain however we do
not know if morta will make a return but
either way it is super exciting that we
are finally getting Doctor Strange to
let me know what you think of this
awesome news and also let me know if you
think Doctor Strange will make an
appearance and spider-man far from home
let me know in the comments below and
again a reminder about the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Applause]